If we do it the classical way,
we give it the objective of, "Fetch the coffee, I must fetch the coffee,
I can't fetch the coffee if I'm dead,"
so obviously the PR2 has been listening to my talk,
and so it says, therefore, "I must disable my 'off' switch,
and probably taser all the other people in Starbucks
who might interfere with me."
(Laughter)
So this seems to be inevitable, right?
This kind of failure mode seems to be inevitable,
and it follows from having a concrete, definite objective.
So what happens if the machine is uncertain about the objective?
Well, it reasons in a different way.
It says, "OK, the human might switch me off,
but only if I'm doing something wrong.
Well, I don't really know what wrong is,
but I know that I don't want to do it."
So that's the first and second principles right there.
"So I should let the human switch me off."
And in fact you can calculate the incentive that the robot has
to allow the human to switch it off,
and it's directly tied to the degree
of uncertainty about the underlying objective.
And then when the machine is switched off,
that third principle comes into play.
It learns something about the objectives it should be pursuing,
because it learns that what it did wasn't right.
In fact, we can, with suitable use of Greek symbols,
as mathematicians usually do,
we can actually prove a theorem
that says that such a robot is provably beneficial to the human.
You are provably better off with a machine that's designed in this way
than without it.
So this is a very simple example, but this is the first step
in what we're trying to do with human-compatible AI.
Now, this third principle,
I think is the one that you're probably scratching your head over.
You're probably thinking, "Well, you know, I behave badly.
I don't want my robot to behave like me.
I sneak down in the middle of the night and take stuff from the fridge.
I do this and that."
There's all kinds of things you don't want the robot doing.
But in fact, it doesn't quite work that way.
Just because you behave badly
doesn't mean the robot is going to copy your behavior.
It's going to understand your motivations and maybe help you resist them,
if appropriate.
But it's still difficult.
What we're trying to do, in fact,
is to allow machines to predict for any person and for any possible life
that they could live,
and the lives of everybody else:
Which would they prefer?
And there are many, many difficulties involved in doing this;
I don't expect that this is going to get solved very quickly.
The real difficulties, in fact, are us.
As I have already mentioned, we behave badly.
In fact, some of us are downright nasty.
Now the robot, as I said, doesn't have to copy the behavior.
The robot does not have any objective of its own.
It's purely altruistic.
And it's not designed just to satisfy the desires of one person, the user,
but in fact it has to respect the preferences of everybody.
So it can deal with a certain amount of nastiness,
and it can even understand that your nastiness, for example,
you may take bribes as a passport official
because you need to feed your family and send your kids to school.
It can understand that; it doesn't mean it's going to steal.
In fact, it'll just help you send your kids to school.
We are also computationally limited.
Lee Sedol is a brilliant Go player,
but he still lost.
So if we look at his actions, he took an action that lost the game.
That doesn't mean he wanted to lose.
So to understand his behavior,
we actually have to invert through a model of human cognition
that includes our computational limitations -- a very complicated model.
But it's still something that we can work on understanding.
Probably the most difficult part, from my point of view as an AI researcher,
is the fact that there are lots of us,
and so the machine has to somehow trade off, weigh up the preferences
of many different people,
and there are different ways to do that.
Economists, sociologists, moral philosophers have understood that,
and we are actively looking for collaboration.
Let's have a look and see what happens when you get that wrong.
So you can have a conversation, for example,
with your intelligent personal assistant
that might be available in a few years' time.
Think of a Siri on steroids.
So Siri says, "Your wife called to remind you about dinner tonight."
And of course, you've forgotten. "What? What dinner?
What are you talking about?"
"Uh, your 20th anniversary at 7pm."
"I can't do that. I'm meeting with the secretary-general at 7:30.
How could this have happened?"
"Well, I did warn you, but you overrode my recommendation."
"Well, what am I going to do? I can't just tell him I'm too busy."
"Don't worry. I arranged for his plane to be delayed."
(Laughter)
"Some kind of computer malfunction."
"Really? You can do that?"
"He sends his profound apologies
and looks forward to meeting you for lunch tomorrow."
(Laughter)
So the values here -- there's a slight mistake going on.
This is clearly following my wife's values
which is "Happy wife, happy life."
(Laughter)
It could go the other way.
You could come home after a hard day's work,
and the computer says, "Long day?"
"Yes, I didn't even have time for lunch."
"You must be very hungry."
"Starving, yeah. Could you make some dinner?"
"There's something I need to tell you."
(Laughter)
"There are humans in South Sudan who are in more urgent need than you."
"So I'm leaving. Make your own dinner."
(Laughter)
So we have to solve these problems,
and I'm looking forward to working on them.
There are reasons for optimism.
One reason is,
there is a massive amount of data.
Because remember -- I said they're going to read everything
the human race has ever written.
Most of what we write about is human beings doing things
and other people getting upset about it.
So there's a massive amount of data to learn from.
There's also a very strong economic incentive
to get this right.
So imagine your domestic robot's at home.
You're late from work again and the robot has to feed the kids,
and the kids are hungry and there's nothing in the fridge.
And the robot sees the cat.
(Laughter)
And the robot hasn't quite learned the human value function properly,
so it doesn't understand
the sentimental value of the cat outweighs the nutritional value of the cat.
(Laughter)
So then what happens?
Well, it happens like this:
"Deranged robot cooks kitty for family dinner."
That one incident would be the end of the domestic robot industry.
So there's a huge incentive to get this right
long before we reach superintelligent machines.
So to summarize:
I'm actually trying to change the definition of AI
so that we have provably beneficial machines.
And the principles are:
machines that are altruistic,
that want to achieve only our objectives,
but that are uncertain about what those objectives are,
and will watch all of us
to learn more about what it is that we really want.
And hopefully in the process, we will learn to be better people.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: So interesting, Stuart.
We're going to stand here a bit because I think they're setting up
for our next speaker.
A couple of questions.
So the idea of programming in ignorance seems intuitively really powerful.
As you get to superintelligence,
what's going to stop a robot
reading literature and discovering this idea that knowledge
is actually better than ignorance
and still just shifting its own goals and rewriting that programming?
Stuart Russell: Yes, so we want it to learn more, as I said,
about our objectives.
It'll only become more certain as it becomes more correct,
so the evidence is there
and it's going to be designed to interpret it correctly.
It will understand, for example, that books are very biased
in the evidence they contain.
They only talk about kings and princes
and elite white male people doing stuff.
So it's a complicated problem,
but as it learns more about our objectives
it will become more and more useful to us.
CA: And you couldn't just boil it down to one law,
you know, hardwired in:
"if any human ever tries to switch me off,
I comply. I comply."
SR: Absolutely not.
That would be a terrible idea.
So imagine that you have a self-driving car
and you want to send your five-year-old
off to preschool.
Do you want your five-year-old to be able to switch off the car
while it's driving along?
Probably not.
So it needs to understand how rational and sensible the person is.
The more rational the person,
the more willing you are to be switched off.
If the person is completely random or even malicious,
then you're less willing to be switched off.
CA: All right. Stuart, can I just say,
I really, really hope you figure this out for us.
Thank you so much for that talk. That was amazing.
SR: Thank you.
(Applause)